et puis vous avez consacré quatre livres
rassemblés sous le titre mythologique à
l'étude des mythes alors dans l'ordre
c'est le cru et le cuit du miel au sens
l'origine des manières de table et
l'homme nu alors est ce que vous
pourriez comme ça veut dire qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un mythe expliquer aux gens
qui ne savent pas ce qu'est ce que c'est
un mythe
parce que là ça a été au final mans
votre terrain de près de prédilection le
mythe
enfin ça a été un de mes dieux grand
terrain de prédilection alors un mythe
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est difficile d'expliquer voir mais
c'est une histoire qui cherche à rendre
compte à la fois de l'origine des choses
des êtres et du monde du présent et de
l'avenir et qui cherche en même temps
simultanément à traiter des problèmes
qui nous apparaîtrait aujourd'hui à la
lumière de notre pensée scientifique
comme tout à fait hétérogènes différents
les uns par rapport aux autres à les
traiter comme s'ils étaient un seul
problème etienne mettait une seule
réponse invite c'est par exemple une
histoire qui essayera d'expliquer à la
fois pourquoi il se trouve que le soleil
est à bonne distance de la terre alors
qu'ils pourraient être beaucoup plus
loin il se serait la nuit éternelle où
beaucoup plus près ils m'ont entrerait
en conflit grâce ion et pourquoi un
homme doit aller chercher son épouse à
bonne distance
pas trop loin parce qu'alors ça pourrait
être une étrangère est unanime y est une
sorcière pas trop près parce que ils se
rendraient coupables du péché d'inceste
et pourquoi également les saisons et les
jours ne se succèdent pas toute vitesse
mais selon un rythme régulier
enfin pourquoi il existe une certaine
bonne mesure à la fois dans l'ordre
cosmologie
dans l'ordre météorologiques dans
l'ordre saisonniers et dans l'ordre
social nous avec nos préoccupations
scientifiques qui avons appris avec des
cartes qu'il faut diviser les
difficultés en autant de parties qui est
requis pour les résoudre
du considérions que ce sont des
problèmes complètement différents et
qu'ils doivent être posées chacun dans
sa perspective propre et résolue dans
ses propres termes le mythe au contraire
assailli de mettre tout ça ensemble et
de trouver une réponse unique à des
problèmes différents
mais je suppose que ces mythes sont
particulièrement vives assez nombreux
dans des sociétés qui n'ont pas
d'écriture bien sûr et dans les sociétés
en fait ils ont pas encore utiliser les
modes de pensée scientifique mais en
réalité quand vous y réfléchissez et
quand vous demandez je ne dirai pas ce
que font les historiens pour qui j'ai le
plus grand respect mais quels usages
nous lui en fait les hommes de la rue
nous faisons de l'histoire et que celui
qui à gauche
enfin voix l'ancien régime et la
révolution française ce qui s'est passé
au 19e siècle d'une façon tout à fait
différente que l'homme de droite ne les
verra au fond est-ce que nous
n'utilisons pas l'histoire
un peu à la façon d'un mythe c'est à
dire en l'organisant de telle façon
qu'elle nous aide ou que nous croyons
qu'elles nous aident à mieux comprendre
notre passé notre position actuelle dans
le monde et les choix politiques que
nous faisons